[Music]
hello everyone Perry back here in Park
City with another exclusive Collider
interview big thanks to Kia for having
us here making these interviews happen
we're talking about a really cool movie
right now it's a who's house his so
there's a lot of folks watching right
now that probably do not know what his
house is just yet so put the duty on
you're probably doing this a lot right
now a brief synopsis of the movie sure
his house is about to refugees who are
given asylum in the UK and I give him a
house but moving in I see and discover
something sinister lurking within it
first future here for you as a director
and you have a really unique background
as far as the content you've made so
whether it be commercials music videos
experimental shorts anything like that
yes what do you think it is about that
experience that really came in handy
making your first feature being able to
experiment all the time trying out
different things exploring with the
actors but also the art department and
the cinematography always trying to find
different ways to tell a story I think
all of those things came in handy and
what was the kind of nugget of an idea
that had this story going in your mind
where did it all begin I think it began
growing up in London and coming from
certain ethnic ethnically diverse
background and experiences of being a
black person in a country where you're
never always feeling like you wanted and
had a feels for a person immigrant
moving to the country and trying to find
their way the future in this place and
how did the cast come together here are
we talking about a traditional audition
process did any of you know each other
before what was really cool actually
about the audition processes for that I
think I did a tape and sent it in and I
got a recall and then the first person I
did a chemistry test with was actually
warming and I'm sure like we both met
with different partnerships
but clearly the first one was the best
one actually you are my only one that's
sorry because you were busy there like
you had you left then she got a flight
straight after I know after when we came
in were like we need to see these two
guys together because awesome and then
you you guys audition together and it
was like it became very easy you guys
are really phenomenal together I am
curious though especially with a movie
that's a two-hander like this when you
find out who's locked in opposite you
and you don't know them do you I don't
know go online and google them and start
looking up their work and everything
well I guess the acting community is
quite small in the UK so I knew off shop
and we had been in we had been in many
rooms together but we weren't mates we
hadn't like hung out on our own
yeah and so I knew that he was a good
guy like I knew that he was he we have
so many mutual friends so you you know
that he's cool if he's hanging out with
your cool friend you know so I wasn't
worried about that actually I was just
and I'd seen his work as well so that
was like okay we're cool
we're good well I was gonna say that
like all of those things are very true
but like when I found out that I might
be working with women I was so proud
because wormies reputation precedes her
for sure it was like she is one of the
most respected actresses in the UK if
not the world very soon I'm sure
so it was like I get to work with me and
all of my friends that you get to work
for me oh my god so like so seriously
this is true I'm not just guessing you
so yeah like get into chem read with her
I just
I made me feel like I had arrived
somewhere that I get to be working with
someone of her caliber you know I would
really but I'm gonna echo everything he
just said cuz between this and I was
just telling you before I saw sweetness
in the belly and we covered it at TIFF
so good oh so good I feel like I want to
cry I'm curious about your onset
collaboration especially with a primary
locate
like that is their opportunity to play
around on set or do you have everything
meticulously planned out given you know
the nature of the story the visuals that
you've constructed and some of the the
really interesting camera tricks that
are pretty chilling but I think part of
being able to explore this by being very
meticulous up fun so planning everything
to a point where you feel confident in
what you're doing so on the day you have
the ability to try that for things
because you always have the core the
structure of Andy to get done what you
need to get done you have to tell me
about working with Javier about tattoo
because he is one of my favorite people
in the industry he is he's really
one-of-a-kind so what was it like
working with him and developing the
stuff he got to do in this he's playful
and creative and loves to get down and a
very professional though he was I mean
he his call time was in like incredibly
long and like he just he didn't mind he
didn't complain and he must have been
hot he must have been he must need the
pee I mean I mean he was just there was
not one complaint or anything he was
just so professional what I thought was
particularly amazing about him was I
could feel his experience you know he
has done this time and time again and at
such a high quality as well that he
would almost he just knew where to be
and how to hold himself and where the
camera was and like how to I think he
helped really facilitated the scene
shooting that scene because of his
experience and I'd love to be able to be
able to do something like that not
necessarily because he is just a
phenomenon but to be able to have such
great experience I can be would you call
it that can help the process of shooting
because I know if it forever has stuck
or something like I'm offering now I
don't know what basically like he was so
experienced that he made
with him so much easier and I learned
lows for me I see a very very technical
seat oh yeah yeah there's there's a lot
of things here that I would imagine are
really technical and incredibly creative
things that I didn't expect and things
that I don't often see in genre movies
which was very refreshing I think of you
as a boss and but I also think we were
surrounded by really really phenomenal
I'm technicians and artists and creators
he really helped make this job a lot
easier
then there were I'm we had a little
family on set and they and we had such a
good time together and we worked so hard
my father some very very heavy material
so is there an opportunity for that
family on set to have you know any
levity in between takes oh absolutely
I mean it was a joy to be on set like it
really was joyful you know this the
subject matter you know when you'll
click into work mode like for rehearsals
for the shooting yes that's that has a
lot of weight but you know when we shout
cook we're like talking about nineties
cartoons together and well now you have
to tell me which one's bananaman well so
we've been animun yeah why have I never
heard of that and that's why I'm Jim
Doug Dogg Ren and Stimpy so one of the
lines that really struck me in the movie
and I'm so I'm so mad we have to wrap up
soon was it's something to the effect of
you know what men can do you think it's
bumps in the night that that frightened
me I'm just curious what it's like
nailing a line that makes such a big
impression like that and also just in
general with horror movies what do you
guys like to watch and
what does scare you in movies this
scared me Tara I mean a lot and I'm not
I don't really watch her as thrillers
even I do I do have to shoot even the
mummy I mean I I jump a lot of things I
jump just walking down the street and so
watching super watching the desert and I
really I what I loved most about the
script was that it wasn't there was such
heart to it that the the trauma isn't
just the horror it's what they've been
through and we are the line of you know
what what I've seen nothing can nothing
can scare her anymore because she's seen
what humanity is capable of and yeah
it's just such a simple line but it just
is so it's just so deep and truthful and
terrifying and I love that like I think
I think that might have been my favorite
line in there I think I think it might
I'll tell you what's my favorite yeah
and I'm not gonna forget that anytime
soon yeah right yeah so wait now are you
into her are you gonna watch the movie
or you can yeah I've seen oh yeah and
it's it's great
my issue is that I watched what lies
beneath when I was 11 and it terrified
me and I think it's like 12 rated movie
15 no no it's definitely not an 18 it's
an underrated film it might be pg-13 but
I was just too young to watch it it's
great but the only problem is that
because I was like traumatized by that
as a child
literally to the point where I couldn't
use the bathroom or go into the toilet
without my parent switch on the light
first to this day I am still looking for
that film that will scare me like there
are lots of films a jump scares are
shocking but in terms of like terrifying
me to the point where I have to like
switch on the light or don't want to go
outside because it's too dark you know
maybe I'm too old and I'm past that
psychological
place but I'm sure there is a film out
there that will just terrify me I'm
getting the wrap-up sign but I can give
you a long long list okay great anything
before we come to a close I hope you
enjoy the film and seen them yeah his
house guys keep an eye out for it thank
you again for being here congratulations
big thanks to Kia for making these
interviews happen at the supper suite in
Park City like and share this one before
you leave it we'll see you soon with
more content from the festival